Chris was so much ego and independent
film you brand yourself a nobody
filmmaker when you've done a lot you've
written for ten hopes blog you've you've
made films why be so self-deprecating
when so there's so much bravado yeah go
against the grain yeah well first of all
that's the truth I am a nobody filmmaker
but it's a deceptive term and it's
actually a term that piques people's
interest so it made for a good blog
article title and i don't mean nobody as
in like in a self-deprecating sense i
mean it nobody as in cultural
significance when I wrote the article
and still to this day I I don't have I
really don't have professional clout yet
I haven't made a film that has starred
anyone significant or has been at any
significant film festivals so
professionally speaking I don't have
again I like to use a term of leverage I
don't have professional leverage so in
that sense I consider myself a nobody
filmmaker meaning that most people
across the United States the world have
never heard of me so I have if you read
the article it really in the end it has
a very optimistic and positive tone and
the revelation for me was that okay I am
a nobody filmmaker I need to embrace
that rather than try to create films
using the leverage model I need to
embrace my limitations my nobody pneus
and create films inspired by those
limitations and what's been the feedback
from that arm it was really good it's
been a while since I wrote it but I just
checked actually the blog post on 10
hopes blog ted has since moved to
indieWIRE but that was on
original truly free film blog and
there's been comments since then I
didn't know about it so I just replied
to some of them yeah it got copied and
pasted on a lot of blogs it was tweeted
numerous times Roger Ebert actually
tweeted it so it was it was a great
first article written for Ted oh so it
was a really good response and people
not only not only people to film
industry responded to it people in the
music business and other creative realms
really responded to it just because of
the kind of universal truth of it hmm
and what was the truth in it was for was
another point well again the main point
is we just we need to be honest with who
we are at who we are as professionals
where we are act in the professional
staircase and I make the argument in the
article that because we are exposed to
so much knowledge wisdom information
through commentaries panels blog posts
by professionals we kind of ingest all
this information and we we become
delusional as nobody's we become
delusional into thinking oh we can do
this too we can call an a-list actors
agent and make them a deal we could
raise five million dollars because this
is a blog post telling you how but the
assumption in these panel discussions
and these articles is the assumption is
that you have the professional leverage
to do that you have you have a over a a
body of work that will open those doors
that the a-list actor will go oh I know
this writer I know this producer I'm of
this director I want to read the script
so that's the main truth in my article
that I believe is true that until you
have that you are nobody so rather than
expend your time and energy trying to do
something that someone higher up on the
professional ladder can do look at
yourself where you're at embrace your
resour
is your limitations and create
accordingly don't waste 5-10 years
trying to raise a million dollars who's
going to give you a million dollars
you've done nothing you know you made a
couple of short films or something but
you have to just be honest with where
you're at and create and do the work and
let the work carry you upwards
you